welcome to another Q&A episode of the
stronger by science podcast in today's
episode Greg and I answer listeners
questions about how and why to warm up
some practical ways to quantify training
volume and assess fatigue how to tell if
you're an on responder to creatine and
much more Plus as an added bonus Greg
gives a very detailed explanation of how
to make any perfect homemade ice cream
remember if you want your questions
answered on a future episode be sure to
submit those questions using one of the
links in the episode description as
always thank you for listening and enjoy
the show
[Music]
welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast this is another Q&A episode I'm
your host Eric Trexler and I'm joined by
temporary guest host Greg knuckles
thanks for having me back on of course
so the first question getting right to
business is a question that comes up all
the time when it comes to looking at
research on hypertrophy and just
practical programming by the way the
question comes from Chuck the one-eyed
dog what is the best way to calculate
volume for hypertrophy training hard
sets regardless of reps reps times wait
time sets question mark yeah so this has
been a topic of a fair amount of debate
so the traditional way to calculate
volume for normalizing programs within
the literature has been to use volume
load which is sets times reps times
weight multiply those together it gives
you your tonnage you know nice happy
number in pounds and kilograms
it feels very scientific because you're
calculating something and that's what
was used pretty much exclusively in the
literature to normalize training
programs or in to equate them for
decades like at least two or three
decades and as best I can tell someone
just started doing that and everyone
else followed suit
there wasn't a rigorous process leading
up to that to make sure that that was
actually
the best way to equate training volume
assuming you're interested and you know
something that will theoretically equate
outcomes as well that was just a
convention and so that's what everyone
did tons of people still calculate their
tonnage as if it actually means
something
however when we look at the research we
see a whole whole lot of instances where
tonnage is different the number of sets
performed is the same and hypertrophy is
the same so most of those studies are
comparing kind of normal moderate rep
moderate load training to low load
training so for example doing sets of 8
to 10 reps per set with about 7075
percent of one rep max to doing sets of
you know 20 to 35 reps per set with
below 50% 1 rep max and virtually all of
the studies that have used that kind of
experimental setup and have equated the
number of sets performed you see very
very similar hypertrophy but much higher
volume loads with the low load training
condition so it seems like the number of
hard sets is a better way to equate
training if you're interested in
hypertrophy outcomes so another thing
I'll just generally note is that even if
you kind of you to the traditionalist
idea of the classic hypertrophy range of
8 to 12 reps per set even there like
volume loads going to be way higher if
you're doing sets of 12 versus sets of 8
it's probably gonna be 30 40 percent
higher give or take so like ultimately I
don't know what you are measuring
besides tonnage it gives you something
to calculate but is it worth calculating
something that doesn't ultimately mean
anything with regards to the training
outcomes you're interested in so just to
nuance this a little bit
when you equate the number of hard sets
pretty close to failure or to failure
that are performed seems like
hypertrophy is pretty similar but
there's there's ins to that range so for
really really low rep stuff so here
probably thinking triples and below you
probably need to do more sets to get
similar hypertrophic outcomes to higher
rep training and if the load gets below
about 30 percent of one rep max it seems
like hypertrophy on a per set basis
starts dropping off as well there was a
recent study testing that where they
compared training at I believe 20 40 60
and 80 percent of one rep max they found
similar hypertrophy with loads between
40 and 80 percent of one rep max but
quite a bit less growth with twenty
percent one rep max so so there are
edges to that range but probably four
sets of between I don't know maybe four
and forty or fifty reps it seems like if
you're doing the same number of sets
hypertrophy on a per set basis is pretty
similar if you get too heavy so probably
you know 85 to 90 ish percent plus like
heavy doubles and triples hypertrophy
drops off if you get below 30 percent 1
rep max I don't know why you ever would
unless you're a subject in one of these
studies but but if that happens probably
a little bit lower hypertrophy per set
but through the range where most people
train in hard set seems to be the way to
go so that is if we're interested in
hypertrophy I think can I make a quick
comment on that yeah gonna mention like
you don't know why somebody would go
below 30 when the first when there's
first a lot of like lively discussion
about the study showing like 30 percent
1 RM even resulting in a decent amount
of hypertrophy even with that I'm like
people were acting like it was some kind
of hack like oh sweet you can only lift
with 30 percent I'm like who wants to do
that man like yeah that's not a fun way
to train at all I mean I could see doing
it for
like curls or tricep extensions or
something if you're just going if you're
kind of masochistic and you're going for
a ridiculous pump and to be in a
reasonable amount of localized agony for
a very long period of time sure but
doing that for like squats or deadlifts
[ __ ] that I was at a conference once and
somebody was sharing their results on
one of those types of studies and they
mentioned that doing bicep curls with 30
percent one rep max one of their
participants developed rhabdomyolysis
doing bicep with it and I believe they
actually ended up publishing a case
report on that subject
that's wild it like can you imagine how
intense that set of curls was man that's
a more intense set of curls and I have
personally ever experienced yeah me too
so the one thing I will say in favor of
volume load is that it it's probably
pretty good if you're trying to predict
the metabolic cost of training so one
thing that we know is caloric
expenditure scales with work perform so
work here in the physics sense and I
mean unless you have a lab set up the
best proxy you're probably gonna get for
that is volume load so I think that that
worrying about volume load if you're
specifically trying to improve work
capacity so just purely the ability to
do work in a session and recover between
sets
I think volume load is probably a pretty
useful metric then or if for whatever
reason you're trying to maximize caloric
expenditure during a training session
volume loads probably a pretty decent
metric then but for just purely interest
in hypertrophy number of hard set seems
to be the way to go
for for most most circumstances now
before I jumped in with my anecdote it
sounded like you were gonna transition
to talking about strength you mentioned
that that was kind of your take when it
comes to hypertrophy so both of the two
things I've said to this point
there's research backing it the strength
thing is just kind of my hot take I
think if you're interested in equating
volume for strength outcomes it's still
the number of hard sets with the caveat
that it needs to be at a relatively high
intensity so about seventy five percent
one rep max or above and they need to be
high quality which is kind of a
subjective thing but I think we've
probably all experienced it where you
know maybe you're doing a bunch of sets
of three and the first four or five are
good and then the sixth set you still
get all the reps but you just feel like
[ __ ] you can tell rep quality's not good
you're not snappy anymore you go for rep
seven maybe you still grind them out but
it sucks even harder I kind of think
that those first five sets are the ones
that are netting you the strength
results that's just my personal feeling
I don't have research to support that
but I think high quality high intensity
sets are the main thing you're
interested in from a strength
perspective just my opinion
so with strength you mentioned that
there was kind of a subjective quality
aspect would that make it fair to say
that there's both an art and a science
to lifting one could say that that would
be a good idea for an e-book I agree or
maybe a pair of e-books okay moving on
to the next question for you Erik from
the asker fitness for teens underscore
and stuff seeing this username and then
the question stereotypes on point I love
it how does marijuana affect recovery
from strengthen hypertrophy training
when is either smoked eaten or vaped
yeah so Erik does this podcast support
vapenation are we are we pro are we a
pro vapenation anti dutch nation podcast
is vape nation is that exactly what it
sounds like or is that like a real thing
it's like a dumb old h3h3 video
okay I'm not I'm not not privy to that
information it's exactly what it sounds
like you know as long as it's adults
making health conscious decisions about
what they want to do with their vaping
habits but maybe not fitness for teens
underscore and stuff
maybe so yeah that's a the disclaimer
here don't do drugs okay if you do drugs
you're gonna have a bad time however I
will answer the question you might be
surprised to find there are not a
tremendous number of randomized
controlled studies looking at resistance
training recovery following vaping
eating and smoking marijuana we just we
just aren't there yet however there is a
decent amount of research on marijuana
in general so there's some useful
information to be shared here now one
thing with marijuana that's interesting
is there is some observational research
indicating that people who tend to
chronically smoked a lot of marijuana
tend to have more visceral adipose fat
and insulin resistance of the adipose
tissue
it's observational so take it or leave
it there is a review by sandstone and
Sansone I'm gonna speculate that they're
either married or related but in that
review they noted there's been a decent
amount of marijuana research on
non-athletic populations and what they
found is that generally speaking
marijuana does seem to affect metabolism
and it seems to increase body weight in
people who are who have a low body
weight initially but in people who are
normal weight or overweight at the
beginning of these types of
interventions there's not a huge effect
on body weight so what you're telling me
is this is that one weird trick for hard
gainers it's not what I'm telling you
that's not what I said that's not I'm
not telling you to initiate your dream
or bulk with a bunch of marijuana but in
any case this so there's some
conflicting information about whether or
not it contributes to
deleterious effects on metabolism there
are some acute studies showing an acute
increase in metabolic rate while you're
actually partaking but I don't know if
it's worth doing much with that I don't
think a lot of people are smoking
marijuana for any kind of perceived
metabolic benefit if you are don't hold
your breath longer now there there there
are a few like review papers talking
about marijuana and how it relates to
athletics and the reason for that is
because marijuana is a banned substance
on drug testing panels so that's
actually changed recently
oh is it yes so I think this changed
three or four years ago okay marijuana
is banned for in competition testing it
is not banned for out of contest testing
for most major organizations so I
including wada is I think it may still
be for the n-c-double-a mmm-hmm I am
almost certain that wada allows athletes
to use marijuana outside of competition
but not if it's in their system during
competition interesting but in any case
if you look back at the research on
failed drug tests historically speaking
marijuana actually tends to be usually
in the top three or four substances that
people get popped with which I didn't
expect it to be that high but there have
been some studies looking at whether or
not there could potentially be an ERG
agenda Cal U to marijuana because people
said well if it's banned in sport let's
see if it actually helps with sport and
it's not our genic which probably
shouldn't be a big surprise the aside
from the potential for long term lung
issues from smoking generally speaking
when you look at performance outcomes it
either hinders performance especially
with things that are taxing on the
cardiovascular system or just has no
effect and there have been some studies
I think some of the individual studies
mentioned like a few that people just
didn't want to work out
that that's believable as hell I think
they had to they had to note that as
subject drop out because I like yeah
they just didn't everyone Fiona kind of
funny no so so a true story
I have per taken in marijuana exactly
four times in my life and I generally
like the idea of it like I'm a fairly
chill guy and I like to lean into that
like if I could take something that
doesn't seem to be all that harmful
especially if you know it's consumed as
an edible and not smoked you know I like
the idea of being even more chill than I
am now you know to wind down in the
evening etc all every time I've used it
I fall asleep immediately but it takes
you know probably 10 20 minutes to feel
anything
I feel better chill relaxed for about
five minutes and then instantly asleep
yeah so I would be one of the people who
would not be working out in this study
yeah it would be unable to wake me up
and that is a good point because even in
these papers usually they'll note like
acutely there's definitely not a
neurogenic effect there's no reason to
believe it would be helpful in terms of
muscle gain or strength gains in any way
mechanistically speaking but they have
noted obviously people subjectively
report better sleep they've they've
argued that there might be some benefit
when it comes to dealing with
performance anxiety or anxiety in
general and athletes and even a
potentially minor minor pain relief from
injury there's a lot of anecdote in the
literature obviously it's kind of it's
it's not easy to study marijuana given
different legal challenges but but that
they have argued okay there might be
some kind of indirect performance
related benefits that might justify
making it banned for sports specifically
but I mean usually when you look at
those drug lists any kind of illicit
street drugs they're pretty much gonna
just put on the list anyway yeah so
given that this asker is fitness for
teens underscore insta it's possibly
worth noting that there is some research
suggesting that regular use of marijuana
during the teenage years is associated
with a permanent decrease in IQ which is
maybe something that someone would want
to be concerned about I like I assume
that's not the case if you know you
spark up a J once a month or something
but if you're someone who regularly uses
marijuana that seems to be what goes
down that is troubling troubling indeed
for personal reasons no I'm just worried
about the general population you know
that's that's very kind of you you've
got these horrible people legalizing
marijuana all over the place which is
just crippling the family unit and
family values that I'd tend to promote
so as you know so one thing to note is
of the research i've seen on the states
that have legalized marijuana the data
that exists tend to indicate that rates
of teen marijuana usage either don't
change or possibly decrease i think it's
one of those things where like once
something's no longer a forbidden fruit
yeah
bunch of [ __ ] teenagers or no are no
longer as interested in it so yeah i
mean that's pretty believable yeah but i
did want to have a couple notes about
CBD because that seems to be a very
popular topic i saw a headline that
caught my eye in a review by an author
named carvalho exposure to CBD is
associated with a reduction in mammalian
testes sighs fertilization rates plasma
concentrations of hypothalamic pituitary
and gonadal hormones
moreover chronic doses have been
associated with
paired sexual behavior in mice it looks
like there's a small body of literature
indicating that chronic exposure to CBD
is pretty not great for the mammalian
reproductive system in males this was
something I wasn't aware of obviously
you would wait for some human trials to
come out on the subject with you know
reasonable exposure dosages but in any
case I found that to be remarkably
troubling indeed something to keep in
mind and to keep an eye on for future
literature that might relate to humans
do we know is there any research looking
at whether those changes are reversible
or not not that I'm aware of very I'm
not certain it's just one of those I
mean with CBD there's just like there
it's everywhere and there's so much
anecdote but comparatively a lot less
research yeah when you look at the
research it has been approved as a drug
for I believe a specific type of seizure
there's some human research looking at
anxiety that seems to be promising but
not entirely conclusive yet but another
thing something that I kind of
speculated about but hadn't found
research on until recently there's a
paper in the journal of the American
Medical Association in 2019 by bond
Miller apparently there's some pretty
serious quality control issues with CBD
products not to be mistaken for fallen
Miller correct this is a very different
but equally cool person I assume Von
Miller seems cool right he seems cool as
hell yeah kidding yeah all right well
you know I just wanted to make sure hell
yeah
you never know if there's somebody that
like you're the last person to hear that
they're actually like terrible and
you're like oh cool guy and then you get
in trouble if I know that someone seems
terrible I'm probably not going to
casually mention them on this podcast
fair enough this this is something we've
run into before it may shock you to
learn Eric I'm not intentionally trying
to torpedo the podcast and I'm a
temporary guest co-host on I know I know
okay but the quality
control CVD in previous episodes I was
like you know what I just don't trust it
but that was based on kind of a gut
feeling I found I finally found a study
about it they looked at 84 products from
31 companies these are CBD supplement
products about 43 percent of them were
under labeled about 26 were over
labelled and about 31 percent were
accurately labeled and I think they
built in about a 10 percent buffer there
so if it was within plus or minus 10 of
labeling I think that's what they
settled with but also they detected a
measurable amount of THC and 18 of the
84 samples which is something that you
know like I said on previous episodes if
you're subject to like a full wada panel
or any kind of drug testing for your job
or your sport in which low levels of THC
might fail you for a drug test I think
that's a really important consideration
yeah I mean especially if it's
especially if it's something where
they're doing sensitive testing and
there's a zero tolerance policy I mean
for sure yeah but yeah so to wrap things
up when it comes to marijuana follow the
wall be healthy be safe kids especially
all you Fitness teens but but yeah I
mean there's really no reason to believe
that there's a direct or gajini effect
there's no reason to believe that there
would be any benefit when it comes to
muscle growth the only stretch you could
make would be just the the extra a
little bit of sleep quality maybe well
in mostly and that it's the number one
tip for hard gainers he heard it here
first folks absolutely not okay let's
let's get to some let's get to some more
mainstream Fitness here's a question
from Barry McGuire fitness and then a
movie Jerry Maguire yeah that was Jerry
Maguire I'm so stupid all right we we
both have bad and different problems
with names yeah you you are unable to
read and for
announced a name that that you read
correct and I'm unable to remember any
name everywhere like there are so here's
a completely true story so after
graduation my wife and I moved out to
California we lived in a house with five
other people one of the guys we lived
with his name was Rob and Rob's
girlfriend also lived there I probably
spent seven to eight hours a day with me
and Rob's girlfriend being the only two
people home because she was unemployed
and I worked from home and so like I
have had untold hours of conversation
with this person but when I first met
her she introduced herself I forgot her
name it reached the point that it was
completely impolite to ask her name
again and so to this day I have no idea
what her name was she will forever be
Rob's girlfriend yeah no there's
definitely a point where it's far too
late yeah you cannot ask but if you're
listening along I mean we try to make
the show pretty practical and applicable
if you're listening along and you find
yourself in a situation like Greg's
here's a little tip that you can use
what you do is you try to find a way to
be in a position where you would
introduce them to somebody else or
introduce someone else to them and then
just seem preoccupied during the actual
introduction mm-hmm so at the time where
you would say hey this is whatever her
name is you just somehow be preoccupied
and it'll look like you're absent-minded
but it won't look like you've not known
their name for eight months no I mean
that that's what I tend thats the play I
try to make yeah it's like this is a
housemate and we didn't have that much
company so like what could I do no you
gotta try to find a way man you know I
never I don't think she ever noticed so
did you ever find out her name no I have
no idea to this day the thing I do is if
if anyone's met me in real life they
know that I refer to
almost everyone is bro like that's my
gender-neutral term either bro or buddy
or dude I don't think that's how gender
neutral works yes you know I lived in
California for six months I can claim
dude as gender-neutral
I have lived in gyms for like 16 years I
can claim bro
as gender-neutral I'll give you dude but
bro stuff okay bro is like saying man
see I think that's gender-neutral too
yeah I mean I I'll refer to my wife is
man and dude and bro like enough yeah
anyway so I just lean into that and if
you refer to everyone as one of those
terms people don't notice that you don't
know their name in particular it just
becomes like a part of how you interact
with people mm-hmm I just I just refer
to people directly as you or if I'm
talking about them I refer to them as an
entity in that way you could virtually
never offend a person by suggesting that
they are in fact some type of entity
sure that's a fact okay let's let's get
back to fitness all right
so Barry McGuire fitness he asked how
important are warmups what constitutes
an effective warmup and what are some
warm-up misconceptions yeah so in
general how important is a warm-up
it's fairly important to do at least
something the exception to that rule is
Keith Maconie or Mick honey I think it's
Maconie very very good 66 kilo weight
lifter in the u.s. APL until very
recently he held I believe the squat
deadlift and total record in that weight
class and a quirk about him which I
learned from talking to other members of
the us's IPF world's team is he doesn't
warm up like he'll do one warm-up set at
like 90% of his opener for every lift
and that's
all the warming up he does so you know
if he's gonna open 500 in a squat he
just waits around until he's about to go
up hits a single at 450 and then goes
and opens with 500 the reason I found
out about this is apparently he got in
trouble with whoever went as the
national team's coach that year when he
was a lifter at Worlds because the coach
wanted everyone to do at least some sort
of warmup and Keith was like nah dude
like that's that's not how I do this and
the coach was like no you have to warm
up and they apparently got in a big
fight about it but but Keith had a had a
string going for a while where I think
for seven consecutive meets he set the
world record for the total and like
repro his own record again so like
obviously worked for him as far as I'm
aware he doesn't have any chronic
injuries he's dealing with so if you're
Keith Maconie you don't have to warm up
I think we can all accept that by this
point for for everyone else you probably
should so what are you trying to
accomplish with a warm-up one is just to
generally raise your core temperature
and also to raise the temperature within
the muscles that you're going to be
using for the workout that accomplishes
two main things so the enzymes that you
use to produce energy really any enzyme
has an optimal temperature at which it
functions best and for the enzymes you
use to produce ATP
their optimal temperature is if memory
serves right around a hundred degrees
Fahrenheit or about thirty eight and a
half degrees Celsius normal body
temperature being ninety eight point six
/ 37 so you want to get the temperature
up in the muscles a little bit just so
the enzymes you're going to be using to
produce energy actually can produce
energy at the fastest clip possible
another thing that happens is your
muscles have viscoelastic properties and
so the
Scoville refers to viscosity and if
you've ever tried to say pour cold honey
versus like microwave honey and then
pour it you can see the difference that
temperature makes on viscosity and
apparently just a few degrees change in
muscle temperature can affect those
viscous properties and thus the elastic
properties of muscle to help its
contractile function work a little bit
better so warming up is very literal one
of the primary things you're trying to
do is just to raise the temperature in
the muscle that you're going to do in
terms of what constitutes an effective
warmup beyond just doing enough general
activity to raise the muscle temperature
the biggest thing you want to do is
movement prep or a dynamic warmup for
whatever exercise you're about to do if
you're a team sport athlete that may be
relatively elaborate because you know
you're about to be doing a bunch of
different stuff you're gonna run you're
gonna jump you're gonna cut you're gonna
move in different planes you're gonna
pivot if you're a lifter you know you're
probably gonna do a relatively basic
exercise moving the bar in one plane
so I tend to think you don't need a very
elaborate warmup and your movement prep
is just you know doing light weight for
the exact exercise you're about to do so
you know if it's squat start with the
bar do the bar for 15-20 reps go up a
little bit do 10 15 reps
whatever just get some blood flow and
lubricate the joints a little bit I tend
to think that's about all most people
probably need to do however I think a
fair amount of an effective warm-up for
an individual depends on that individual
and depends on the feel so for example I
would never claim that everyone should
do lacrosse ball rolling on their hips
their piriformis their glutamine before
they squat and deadlift there's no
evidence that it's effective most of the
research looking at the effects of foam
rolling or self myofascial
lease on subsequent performance finds
that it doesn't really do much like
nothing interesting on average so I
wouldn't say Oh everyone needs to do
this but I know for me personally it
makes a big difference so I do it in and
I think that warm-up should probably be
tailored in that fashion so if as you
start building up to your main work sets
on whatever movement you're starting
with if you're frequently finding that
something just feels bad or feels off
you know try different dynamic stretches
try different maybe even static
stretches try foam rolling particular
muscles see if something just
subjectively makes you feel better if it
does pull add that to your warm-up but
there's very few things that everyone
has to do beyond just very basic
movement prep I find it interesting that
you mentioned that foam rolling and
lacrosse ball type work helps for you
because I also subjectively feel quite a
difference when I do those types of
things before a big squat or a deadlift
workout and I've heard you talk about
the research on self myofascial release
before and I would have assumed that you
thought it was all completely BS I had
no idea you actually did some of that
yourself yes oh okay I'm gonna come in
with a sweltering hot decidedly not
evidence-based take here we go actually
I guess it kind of is it's so the
principle that absence of evidence isn't
evidence of absence if you look at the
foam rolling literature the vast
majority of what gets rolled it's either
quads or hamstrings like that's pretty
much what every study looks at I haven't
seen a study that looks at getting a
lacrosse ball there in your piriformis
or glued need for me personally foam
rolling my quads and hamstrings doesn't
do [ __ ] like my personal experience very
much matches the research there but for
me and a fair amount of people I know
getting getting in your your lateral hip
area makes a big difference so I mean
it very well could just be one of those
things where you know maybe that type of
stuff
does make a difference but there just
hasn't been research looking at the
right muscles yet so yeah someone's
probably gonna crucify me for that but
whatever it's well-deserved if not for
that you've done plenty sure the yeah so
in general basic movement prep and just
doing light reps with whatever exercise
you're gonna do I think that's plenty of
warm-up for most people but yeah if the
movement doesn't feel good just play
around with other things that may feel
good for you personally I think the
biggest misconception just building off
of everything I just said is that
anything beyond a basic movement prep is
necessary for everyone there are a lot
of people who absolutely swear by foam
rolling they say oh you have to roll
every muscle in your body before you
even think about touching a barbell
that's dumb what's what's the thing that
was popular like three or four years ago
the [ __ ] voodoo floss or whatever
that was like a thing for a while people
saying everyone has to do that no
research on that like no everyone
doesn't have to do that a lot of like
traditional strength coaches are still
into like a very thorough dynamic warmup
before anyone even considers touching a
barbell I also think that's completely
overkill like I think it makes a ton of
sense for sports practice not so much
for the weight room but yeah I mean
beyond just basic movement prep doing
light weight with the exercise you're
about to do I don't think there's
anything that everyone just needs to do
beyond that so next question for Eric
from JV DM 94 is any incline chest work
worth it
does it increase the size of your upper
chest that is an interesting question
from the perspective of a bodybuilder I
think if you ask the typical bodybuilder
how do you feel about only doing flat
bench the rest of your life they would
probably be quite concerned that their
overall chest development would be
hindered by that there's a few ways to
look at answering this question
first there's the research looking at
bench press at different angles and how
that affects the activation of different
areas of the pectoral muscles and
generally speaking the flat bench press
is pretty damn good at broadly
activating the PEC musculature there are
some studies showing that if you play
with the angle you can preferentially
get a little bit extra activation in
certain areas of the muscle so there is
some evidence to suggest that doing some
incline pressing might give you a little
bit more preferential activation of the
upper chest area that doesn't
necessarily mean that you're going to
have additional hypertrophy there
there's you know OMG activity does not
necessarily translate over time to
hypertrophy but there is a study not not
on incline bench press but I think I
think it's informative when it comes to
variation and exercise in general
there's a study a few years back where
they looked at leg your quad hypertrophy
using squat only or a program that had a
variety of exercises so they had squat
deadlift
leg press and lunges and what they found
was the overall amount of hypertrophy in
the quads globally was similar between
the groups but the group that did a
variety of exercises they had more
uniform growth across the quadriceps so
when they looked at all the different
quad muscles individually and saw even
though it was the same relative amount
of growth in general it was more uniform
looking at the various components of the
quads and so I take a somewhat similar
approach when it comes to training the
upper body musculature and just one
thing to note about that study is the
group doing a variety of exercises was
also doing one of them was leg press or
not light press was a deadlift I mean
yeah which one would very much assume on
a set per set basis does not
train your quads as hard as squats and
just because range of motion is slightly
smaller as well I would assume lunges
probably don't train your quads quite as
hard as squats do either so if anything
that study kind of stacked the balance
in favor of squats if anything and still
found better uniformity of hypertrophy
with the variety of exercises which I
think if anything makes it even more
striking yeah and so there's that aspect
of it also so when I think of my chest
volume throughout the week I out some
training principles from the other Eric
Eric Helms Eric to smaller font Eric
so Helms you know he got he kind of
planted the idea in my head he was
saying he was training like five days a
week or something and they're basically
five full-body sessions and he was
dividing up his volume across the I'm
paraphrasing but something along those
lines a lot of full-body work throughout
the week and so I've been doing
something similar so I'm probably
averaging three or four chest workouts a
week but that they're low volume per
session but with my chest work aside
from looking at details of muscle
activation and stuff like that what I
find is if I were doing all of that
volume on flat bench press my wrists
elbows and shoulders would probably be
pretty unhappy with me just based on my
personal training experience when I vary
that a little bit so right now I have a
flat bench workout I've got an incline
unilateral dumbbell bench workout and
I've got a flat dumbbell workout and I
find that the variety of allowing joints
to just slightly different angles on
those three exercises I think it does
help me out in the long term of just not
overloading the joint at a very specific
angle over and over and over so for me
even aside from preferentially targeting
one area the muscle or another
just keeping my joints feeling healthy
and fresh it has been a really nice a
really nice benefit of messing with some
of those
pressing angles so my short answer would
be I would say for me you might you
probably disagree with this based on a
discussion we've had in the past but I
would say my best chess builder if I had
to pick one exercise forever I would
choose the flat barbell press I know
previously you completely disparage the
flat barbell press on an old episode did
I it was like your first go-to for
overrated exercises well because I think
it's overrated doesn't mean I think it's
bad I mean it is the avatar of exercises
that everyone thinks about when they
think resistance exercise yeah like how
much of inch bro it's like your study
right you ask people like how many years
they've been lifting six how many of you
been benching exactly six yeah the
second you start lifting you're benching
yeah so I mean something can still be a
good exercise and be tremendously
overrated like those yeah that's not
logically inconsistent well I'm not a
not a nuanced thinker so I try to boil
things down to the important parts but
but what I'm getting at is if you just
benched from here on out and he
developed a really strong bench you did
it with decent volume frequency
intensity you would develop a strong big
well-developed chest not disputing that
no one's gonna look at your physique and
say oh crap that guy's been skipping out
on the incline presses because the I
think the flat bench press does activate
the PEC pretty globally and pretty
effectively but I do think there is
benefit of including that incline chest
work especially if you're a bodybuilder
or you know extremely comprehensive
balanced chest development is
particularly important to you not to
mention the fact that incline chest work
usually also gives some nice stimulation
to the anterior deltoids as well yeah I
mean I I like the I like the point you
brought up about just generally keeping
joints happier I also cycle through
lifts pretty frequently for very much
the same reason I think it's I think
it's not quite as extreme but it's a
similar principle
- endurance athletes doing
cross-training
so like runner who just runs year-round
generally has a greater risk of like
chronic muscle or joint issues then
someone who you know does most of their
training running but also mixes some
biking and swimming in as well still
getting the aerobic work but also not
loading the exact same motor pattern
over and over and over again it's
obviously much more subtle like
comparing benchpress to incline press
like versus running versus cycling like
it's it's a smaller difference but I
think the same principle applies and
I've I've noticed the same thing like if
I do especially like comp deadlifts all
the time
[ __ ] me up same thing for bench and
squat but to a lesser degree but just by
keeping a rotation of exercises and
feel so much better yeah also the tip of
the hat - Helms I've been really
enjoying this type of training if
anyone's interested in learning more
about that Eric talked about it in a
pretty fair amount of depth on Jeff in
the burt's channel a while back if you
want to check out that video cool
alright so great we got a question from
Arminius the question how is the concept
of functional overreaching applicable in
a hypertrophy training block and how
often would you advise to use this
technique to build onto that how would
you best reap the benefits of the super
compensation following a successful
overreaching period so up to about six
months ago I would have said how
relevant is the concept of functional
overreaching to hypertrophy I would have
said not at all and I think I would have
had pretty decent reason for saying that
you train you stimulate muscle protein
synthesis within 48 to 72 hours it seems
like muscle protein synthesis goes back
to baseline
and it kind of stays at baseline until
you train again there's gonna be some
fluctuations based on how recently
you've eaten a protein containing meal
with a high amount of leucine but for
the most part you get that spike around
the workout goes back to baseline a few
hours later or if a couple days later
and that seems to be the general process
so I would have said you know if you're
gonna do functional overreaching and you
know maybe then D load and you're hoping
for a big rebound in hypertrophy
I would have said that's dumb like a
couple days after the last workout of
your functional overreaching block
muscle protein synthesis is back to
baseline you're not going to get
anything extra out of that however there
was a recent study by bjornsen and
colleagues which did show that
functional overreaching and kind of a
subsequent overshoot and hypertrophy is
a thing but I still don't know how
relevant it is to most people so in this
study the subjects were untrained and at
the training protocol was kind of
contrived so they had two blocks of five
days of training separated by ten weeks
Bert not ten weeks by 10 days so they
trained for five days they did seven
training sessions during those five days
so the first three days they trained
once per day the last two days they
trained twice per day
these were low intensity very high rep
sessions bunch of sets taken to failure
this may have been the study that you
talked about where someone had rhabdo
I think if memory serves when I reviewed
this study for mass there there was
either one or two subjects that they
said they had to drop because their
creatine kinase levels were getting
completely out of control and if you
look at even like group level the
bjornsen study yeah I was I was this
ain't it so there must be a lot of
rhabdo
I mean I could be misremembering it but
I I do remember that the initial spike
in creatine kinase even on the group
level was outrageous that's plausible I
mean yeah people get rhabdo Sharyl over
but yeah so very very challenging
training for completely untrained folks
five days of training ten days of no
training another five days of training
just running back the training program
from the first five days of three days
with training to failure once per day to
Train to two days of training to failure
twice per day and then they took various
measures of hypertrophy after the last
session three days after the end of the
study ten days after the end of the
study and I don't think they took
hypertrophy measures twenty days after
but they did take strength measures but
as far as hypertrophy goes
they found that fibre hypertrophy so
when they took a biopsy and looked at
the cross sectional area of type 1 and
type 2 muscle fibers it was the highest
ten days post training so it was higher
at 10 days after the last workout than
three days after the last workout and
the difference was was actually
reasonably large so at least on a fiber
level there did seem to be a delayed
hypertrophic response and kind of a
rebound and overshoot in fibre size
after an overreaching bloc of training
for untrained folks this was absolutely
over training or overreaching
however for someone who is interested in
the appearance of hypertrophy I don't
know how relevant it is because they
also took ultrasound scans to get whole
muscle cross-sectional area and that was
basically unchanged for the vastus
lateralis and the rectus femoris from
three days post training to ten days
post training so they saw an increase in
fiber size but they didn't see a
increase in whole muscle volume it very
well could have been a situation where
three days post training there
is a fair amount of edema and then by 10
days post training the actual amount of
muscle tissue itself had increased but
edema had gone down so the muscles
themselves and it actually looked that
much bigger but yeah on a fiber level
you know seemed like functional
overreaching and then subsequent delayed
hypertrophy was a thing whole muscle
level not much going on so I think we
can say that the concept is possible but
I don't I still don't have much
confidence in it because one the
training programs were kind of over the
top not the way most people would
approach training too
the subjects were untrained we don't
know whether that this would apply to
trained lifters or not and three like
most people who care about hypertrophy
want their whole muscles to look big
we're not taking biopsies of ourself to
flex on insta and say like well look at
that my type one fibers got seven
percent larger suck it haters you know
like you want your actual muscles
themselves to look bigger
so anyway I think it's possibly a thing
there's an alum there's not not much
research on it so I kind of revert to my
original stance of I don't think it is
really all that relevant or useful in
the real world yeah so I think part of
the question was so if it does exist or
if it is useful like how how would you
best reap the benefits would you said
just leave it don't worry about it yeah
so I mean the thing with any sort of
overreaching because you see this with
strength as well like in some of the
research that tests peaking models what
they might do is you know have people
ramped up their training volume for two
or three weeks performance decreases a
little bit during that time span they D
load them performance increases and it
increases above the level it was prior
to the overreaching block and they're
like oh look overreaching is good we see
this overshoot and strength this is
awesome
the problem is that's not testing the
counterfactual so you know let's say
during those three weeks of overreaching
and then subsequent two weeks of
tapering you get a five percent decrease
in strength and then from the lowest
point there you get a seven percent
increase in strength and you wind up two
percent stronger than you were
previously you're not testing the
counterfactual of just doing four weeks
of normal ass training during which time
you may have gotten two percent stronger
doing normal ass training you know so
I'm I'm kind of skeptical of the concept
of functional overreaching in the first
place I think people think it works
because you get that performance
decrease you taper you D load you bring
that fatigue back down and then over the
span of a week or two you do you do get
a pretty big spike in performance but
you get a spike in performance from a
depressed level such that it's probably
not better or all that much better than
it would have been had you not done the
overreaching block in the first place
so yeah I'm you're basically like
masking your performance gains and then
removing the mask right yeah so I so I'm
kind of skeptical about whether
functional overreaching is is that
useful in the first place for either
strength or hypertrophy okay all right
next question for you Eric from Beth s
kW can you tell if you're a creatine
non-responder by whether or not you gain
weight when you start taking it for
example if your weight is the same after
a week of taking a loading dose this
question comes up a lot there there are
some research methods to figure this out
you know we could do a biopsy or we
could do
magnetic resonance spectroscopy which is
super intense imaging those are the ways
in a research study that you would try
to figure out if somebody's a responder
or not and really what you're looking at
there is when we gave them the creatine
did their muscle storage of creatine
increase in response to that
intervention and it's kind of because
the methods of measuring that are
invasive or hard to do like hard to have
access to inexpensive what's interesting
about the non-responder problem is we
have some estimates about like what
percent of the population might be a non
responder but from a technical
perspective they're not super robust
estimates I mean I mean it's like it's
based on probably I would say like a
handful of papers none of which had more
than like twenty or thirty people so
we've pretty much made like a global
estimation from like a total of like
sixty people it's like one of those
studies you see where in the title it
says they're providing normative data
about something and they have like 40
subjects god that drives me crazy yeah
so so when people say like how many
non-responders are there it's like the
current estimates like I don't know
twenty thirty percent of people maybe
but it's based on some very small sample
research and not many like you can do
small sample research and do like a
million samples and all of a sudden
you've got a pretty decent estimate but
not a ton of studies that really
directly have have tried to hit this
question head-on well and another
question is like especially with small
samples you have to wonder whether the
samples you have are biased mm-hm so you
know most most people who are going to
be signing up for a study taking place
in in exercise physiology Department
somewhere tend to at least be somewhat
interested in resistance training and so
like people who tend to be interested in
resistance training also tend to eat a
fair amount of meat one of the things
you noted in your article about creatine
that that we published on the site a
while back was that people who
a fair amount of meat and you know
particularly non vegetarians non vegans
are likely to have higher bass levels of
creatine in their muscles and are
probably more likely to be
non-responders just because they have
more creatine to start with and so like
this the studies out there could have an
artificially inflated rate of
non-response because they may be a bunch
of people who are already interested in
resistance training and are already
eating a bunch of meat and are therefore
more likely to be non-responders than
the general population would be so if
it's a 20-30 percent non-response rate
in those studies general population you
know could be 10 percent we don't know
yeah and another thing to consider is
you know sometimes we have a concept of
non-response in Physiology where it's
like oh I was born with a defective
receptor for that yeah like it it
doesn't work for me and it works for
other people when we talk about creatine
it's really a spectrum of responses it's
how much does your tissue creatine
increase when you change your intake and
so that that's another thing that's
really important is that it's not an on
respond or responder thing really and
it's more of to what magnitude do you
respond and some people it's gonna be
almost nothing some people it's gonna be
a huge change and most people are gonna
be somewhere in the middle so that's one
thing to keep in mind is that it's not
like some kind of thing where you're
either gonna feel it or you're not it's
it's a spectrum and it's it's hard to
tell very easily without some kind of
direct measurement like is this working
or not so in theory weight gain should
be a helpful metric usually when we do a
study with creatine intake we will see
that the creatine group gains more
weight than the placebo group one thing
to keep in mind there though if you
don't have the benefit of doing this on
two groups of people with a big sample I
mean you're just doing this at your
house right it's just you one thing to
keep in mind is if you start
loading and because you're drinking you
know for extra beverages a day like you
might just be waterlogged it's like
you've just added like an additional
like 70 ounces of fluid to your
day-to-day fluid intake so like at first
you might just be heavier because you're
drinking a ton more so that's something
that's going to cloud your perception of
that kind of N equals one experiment so
you have to keep that in mind now
theoretically as I was saying we should
see an increase in body weight and that
should be due to the fact that when you
get on creatine you increase storage of
creatine if you're responder that
creatine is ozma lytic so it should draw
water into the cell and increase
increase your total body water usually
it'll cause a a gain of you know one to
three pounds or something like that over
a short period of time now one of the
things that I find interesting is if you
look at the research trying to determine
like is all of the fluid storage
intracellular because a lot of
bodybuilders are interested in that
because they're like I don't want any
extracellular fluid I want it all in the
muscle cell the experimental research
actually doesn't indicate that it's like
exclusively intracellular water storage
and it's not even close to being
exclusively intracellular when you look
at the experimental data so it looks
like the intracellular storage probably
drives the gain and water weight at the
intracellular of storage of the creatine
and I think what's happening is that
creatine within the cell is ozma lytic
does draw water into the cell but I
think your body is a lot smarter than
you and it hasn't it kind of naturally
self-corrects and make sure that the
relative ratio of intracellular to
extracellular fluids are relatively
balanced I kind of view it almost like
when you try to really mess around with
sodium and potassium balance and like
generally speaking your body will do a
pretty good job correcting it and then
when your
body can no longer correct it you die
yeah so you would expect the ratio of
intracellular water to extra cellular
cellular storage when you do this kind
of creatine loading intuitively you
would be like oh well it's all going to
get stored in the cell the experimental
data don't really support that very well
but if you're a bodybuilder and that
makes you concerned just because it's
extracellular fluid does not mean it's
subcutaneous water storage so I mean
extracellular water is a very broad
compartment of fluid it does not mean
it's gonna make you look bloated or
watery or less lean and anecdotally the
driest to use a colloquial term the
driest leanest looking bodybuilders
you've ever seen on stage a ton of them
took creatine that morning so it's not
something to be concerned about but is
something I find interesting because you
often hear people say all of its gonna
get stored in the cell but the data
don't seem to support that in any case
the best tools we have to try to figure
out if you're a responder or not you
could try to use weight but again weight
fluctuates a lot anyway I mean day to
day your weights gonna fluctuate a ton
you're gonna introduce probably at least
40 to 50 additional ounces of fluid per
day when you start loading so that's
gonna really distort your judgement of
body weight but if you can look at that
trend over a month or so and say oh yeah
it looks like I've ticked up you know a
kilogram and a half that could be
informative what I usually tell people
is to focus more on performance do you
know if you want to do loading fine if
not if you take it for a month you
should be good to go if you look at your
training log and say wow the last month
seems to be a little bit better than a
typical month would be for training that
might be a good indicator that you are a
responder it could also be an indicator
that you have a effectively placebo
yourself but if your training log looks
good and your training adaptations are
good and the creatine is really cheap
and the creatine is really safe I'm not
sure that's such a bad thing and that's
my heartache no I agree
so I actually have a creatine question
for you Eric okay
so something I'd never run up against
but since you know everything about
creatine I figured if anyone would know
the answer to this it would be you
that's a lot of pressure to put on
somebody before you ask the question so
I was recently tagged in a thread on
reddit where someone said they don't
want to take creatine because it's too
bitter
they said they were taking creatine
monohydrate power or powder they linked
to it I forget the brand but it was some
like bulk wholesale retailer retailer it
proclaimed to be playing creatine
monohydrate wasn't from like it wasn't a
flavored product from GNC or something
like that and I said I shouldn't be
bitter like it may not actually be
creatine monohydrate creatine
monohydrate is supposed to be a chalky
generally tasteless powder and then
multiple other people chimed in on the
thread most of them saying like yes I
take this exact same product it's
tasteless and then a handful of more
people were saying I take this product
and it does taste pretty bitter to me so
what I was wondering is like whether
it's more likely that whatever company
that was just had a bad run of the
product and maybe it was tainted with
something or whether creatine tasting
might work kind of like cilantro or like
papaya so for people who don't know
cilantro generally tastes cilantro II
for most people and then for some folks
it tastes terrible
they think it tastes like soap papaya
tastes generally good and papaya II for
most people and then for some people it
tastes terrible it tastes like vomit so
I'm wondering if you know anything about
taste perception and creatine and
whether there might be some sort of
weird taste quirk where some people
would perceive it as better so I'm not
aware of that
this is one of those questions that the
best person to ask would be like an
industry insider like a formulator you
know somebody who's seen every blend and
permutation of creatine and all
different sorts of temperatures and ph's
and all that mm-hmm at first I thought
you were gonna tell me when you start
when you said bitter I thought you were
telling me a horror story and it turned
out they gave him caffeine instead and
now he's dead I shouldn't laugh at that
no that happened I mean I've never heard
of a manufacturer mislabeling creatine
as caffeine but it's quite common that
people take caffeine and it seems that
they've mixed it up with their other
supplements mm-hmm because every I think
everybody knows caffeine is very bitter
on its own yeah so I thought you were
going there with that and I was like god
I hope not
no one one thing that comes to mind it
could be just a subjective difference in
taste I wonder so any creatine product
in powder form
if you chemically analyzed it I'm pretty
sure it's gonna be some amount of
creatine and some amount of creatinine
in the product I wonder if it's possible
that they had a kind of crappy batch
that just had a more creatinine in it
maybe maybe that has more of a bitter
flavor profile that is an absolute
random stab in the dark a complete guess
but I have not heard that but if I took
it if I took an unflavored creatine
product and it was bitter I would be
pretty concerned it would almost
certainly stop taking it yeah my I mean
we've talked about quality control
issues in the supplement industry
multiple times on this podcast already
so so my my hunch is that it was
probably just a bad run of the product
right but if there were variations in
taste perception I figured if anyone
would know about it it would be you I I
have never heard that but I I might text
somebody about that I think I might know
somebody who could tell us something
about that
so podcast listeners if I get any useful
information I will report
back cool all right on to the next
question from physio strength NYC what
would you say is the most pragmatic and
valid way to objectively measure fatigue
so I'm not actually going to answer this
question well it's a I will but it may
not be the answer you're looking for
the most pragmatic and valid way to
objectively measure fatigue is probably
not the best way to measure fatigue I
say that because there was a meta not or
not a meta-analysis there was a
systematic review that came out not not
all that long ago I want to say 2016
title was monitoring the athlete
training response : subjective
self-reported measures Trump commonly
used objective measures : a systematic
review and the title kind of gives the
game away there so based on the measures
of stress and fatigue that we have it
seems that subjective measures tend to
work better than objective measures both
for predicting subsequent changes in
performance and also for predicting the
deleterious things that tend to come
with excess fatigue so here we're
talking about increased injury risk risk
of developing infections or illness
which can happen with with overtraining
so it seems that for the most part
subjective assessments of perceived
energy perceived stress perceive fatigue
perceived mood tend to do a better job
of actually assessing athlete fatigue
than objective measures do an exception
to that might be if you are purely in
aerobic athlete heart rate variability
seems to be a pretty decent indicator of
fatigue in aerobic athletes almost all
of that research is either looking at
aerobic athletes or like heart failure
patient
there's I think one study on strength
athletes and it was looking at using HRV
to kind of like assign training
frequency and not so much how well it
tracked with some like gold gold
standard measure of fatigue which I'm
not really even sure what that would be
so yeah
objective measure is not that good
subjective measures pretty good if you
have some sort of sleep tracking device
if you're interested in something
objective that could be pretty decent as
well so a leading indicator of fatigue
and overtraining
that often not always but often kicks in
before you actually start seeing drops
in performance is sleep quality and
duration start decreasing so you're
really tired but you can't sleep they're
waking up more frequently in the middle
of the night takes longer to fall asleep
etc generally if you're tired you're
supposed to be able to sleep like a baby
or you know maybe you're just someone
who has sleep issues all the time and
you still just have sleep issues all the
time but if you generally sleep good and
you generally sleep better when you're
fatigued and suddenly you're even more
fatigued and you're suddenly sleeping
worse that is that is a marker of
fatigue and possible overtraining that
you can quantify objectively if you have
some sort of sleep tracker device but
you can also quantify that subjectively
I think like most of us know if our
sleep quality sucks
or at least have a pretty decent idea of
it so yeah most most pragmatic and valid
objective thing you can use HRV if
you're an endurance athlete maybe some
sort of sleep monitor for anyone else
but for the most part subjective
measures of mood and perceived fatigue
and stress seem to be more useful for
most athletes alright question for Eric
man I'm gonna be the one to [ __ ] up the
name now I'm going to say Murr to look
underscore eric is fasting more
effective than simply calorie
restriction when it comes to retaining
muscle mass whilst losing body fat
whilst hell yeah that's um that's a
Middle English [ __ ] I am I'm feeling
that well I'm glad that you're feeling
it yeah I hope you give a good answer to
this person who must
asked a good question I'm actually going
to abstain and I think you know why look
at the question dude you're the one who
picked out your questions to answer
know it that in the question two human
beings are tagged oh okay
Greg knuckles and the other Eric Eric
Alice listen nobody cares about Eric
Helms he doesn't know anything about
nutrition or training why do people keep
tagged them in these things he's a joke
did you put this [ __ ] question in the
outline just to get a dig in at Eric Elm
no no actually I like this question okay
I was I was gonna say because that's
that's either really petty or a good bit
I know it's a good bit but that would
have been really fun to play a super
petty alright so I don't go on and on
about this because we did this question
was asked before we did our big
intermittent fasting episode so we've
kind of touched on it but if for some
reason you're behind and you haven't
listened to that episode when we talk
about fasting obviously fasting in
general is catabolic that's how that
works right like the general concept of
fasting certainly would not be
considered something that you would
expect to promote or retain muscle mass
particularly effectively but I think
this question is referring more to like
intermittent fasting strategies which
can take a few different forms there's
the in the research literature
intermittent fasting usually refer
to some kind of alternate day fasting
where you might fast for every other day
or a couple days a week or just like one
day early in the week one day later in
the week quite a few different ways to
do that and what's interesting is with
those studies you know the typical idea
based on what we know about protein
timing would be if you're fasting two
days out of the week you know you're
gonna miss so many opportunities for
protein feeding all of your lean mass is
gonna fall off you're gonna go super
catabolic realistically looking at those
interventions the differences in lean
mass aren't aren't really notable
however those are in untrained people
who you know don't have a ton of muscle
to start with they're not doing
resistance training they're pretty
sedentary and they're generally
overweight or obese
so I don't want to over interpret those
findings when it comes to people that
are resistance trained we have some
research on other other approaches that
are referred to as intermittent fasting
but the really time restricted fasting
so time restricted feeding right yes
time restricted feeding and so with
those strategies you would consume all
your calories for the day within a short
window usually it's like four to eight
hours the studies we see on resistant
trained people there was one study that
did show the lean mass gains and the
performance gains the strength gains
were a little bit impaired by the inner
minute fast or the time restricted
feeding compared to a control diet but
in that study it was a four hour feeding
window and the overall protein intake
was pretty low for that day it was only
like one gram per kilogram the control
group was eating I think one point for a
pretty meaningful difference in protein
intake grant Tinsley who's been on the
show has done two studies the last
couple years I think the lead author of
one was more oh but but Tinsley was on
the paper but there have been a couple
studies coming out using an 8 hour
feeding window in which the lean mass
gains or the retention of lean mass were
basically equivalent
and performance outcomes were basically
equivalent and I know definitely in the
most recent one where Tinsley was the
lead author one of the a couple of the
the things they were really careful
about was making sure there was enough
total protein intake each day I think it
was about 1.6 grams per kilogram and
they also made sure that the training
wasn't performed in the fasted State and
so I'm starting to really view protein
timing a little bit more liberally than
I used to it looks like if you're
training hard you're doing plenty of
resistance training that that seems to
have a really notable impact on how long
the anabolic stimulus from a protein
feeding lasts and it also seems to
sensitize your muscle to the anabolic
response to protein feeding for a very
extended period of time so for up to 24
hours after a lift you seem to be kind
of hypersensitive to the muscle protein
synthesis response to a protein feeding
and so you know some of these very
applied studies are indicating honestly
even if you're only having I mean an 8
hour feeding window you could really
only have probably three solid protein
feedings in that I mean to consider them
really discrete meals yeah it looks like
that's pretty sufficient to within the
studies we've seen so far now
does that change when we're talking
about super extreme deficits and people
getting super duper lean maybe there
could be a slight benefit to muscle
retention with different meal meal
timing with the protein but generally
speaking fasting doesn't seem to be more
effective for muscle retention but it
doesn't seem to be notably worse if
you're following those general
principles of enough protein per day I
would say an 8 hour feeding window so
far looks a little a little bit more
favorable than a 4 hour but there are
other methodological differences with
those studies that you can't necessarily
say it's just the time of the fee
window but generally speaking if you
wanted to err on the safe side and use
some kind of intermittent fasting
strategy and your resistance trained I
would say that the way to go would
probably be an eight hour feeding window
make sure you have plenty of protein
each day and don't train in the fasted
State I think that would be just as good
as a more traditional meal pattern yeah
I mean I think the key here is really
that the dose makes the poison yeah I
think that a lot of people have a
tendency to look at things in a binary
way either you know you have a
traditional like 16 hour feeding window
or you're doing some sort of fasting and
clearly there's some point that you can
reach at which fasting can become
deleterious so eight hour feeding window
seems to be fine
four hours may be fine maybe a little
worse if you took it to the extreme and
you just eat 6,000 calories in one meal
every three days I don't think anyone
would expect that that is just as good
as a traditional feeding pattern so you
know it at some point it can become too
much but up to that point it seems to be
just as good and eight hours in an eight
hour feeding window seems to be within
that range where you're not fasting so
much that it becomes deleterious yeah
the one thing you know it asked is
fasting more effective I think we've
kind of explained we're fasting would
successfully fit into two kind of a
feeding strategy or feeding schedule but
one thing I would note is one of the
benefits of having kind of a time
restricted feeding window the the
literature many times has shown a
benefit in terms of satiety so if you're
on a calorie restricted diet and you're
struggling to deal with hunger
it's always very subjective you want to
play around with it a little bit but a
lot of people do notice that when they
restrict their feeding window it makes a
low-calorie diet a lot more bearable a
lot more tolerable in turn
their hunger and their desire to eat
which are two different things I think a
lot of people forget that like even if
it didn't help your physiological true
hunger a lot of people find it to be
really beneficial to just mentally take
a break and say I know I'm not eating
for a while and I'm cool with that yeah
I think I think people underestimate the
benefits that hard rules and
restrictions can have for some people I
mean I think that's the exact same thing
as the old like bodybuilder adage of
donee carbs after 6:00 p.m. yeah like
there's nothing magical about avoiding
carbs after 6:00 p.m. but like most
delicious things have carbs in them if
you're trying to restrict calorie intake
you know having a hard cutoff at some
point in the night for when you eat
delicious foods is probably going to
cause you to eat fewer delicious foods
and naturally decrease your calorie
intake definitely now it's time for the
most important question of the night ok
so this is a question a lot of people
have been asking the the fitness world
is kind of going crazy wanting answers
about this so we figured we would set
aside some time and just air it out and
tell everybody everything they want to
know so the question is for Gregg and
it's really a collection of questions
that I mean we're getting them from all
from all sides these days people want to
know Gregg the ice cream that people see
on Instagram for Billy I don't know
stronger by science is a family we have
dinners every weekend I always come over
and bring a bunch of terrible food and
Greg makes a bunch of great food and it
works for everybody but lately he's been
making his own ice cream posting it on
Instagram and I promise you as a person
who has tried all of it
it is incredible so Greg help the people
out what how do you make the ice cream
taste so damn good yeah so ice cream ice
cream is hard to make bad right so
you're you have something with high fat
content and high sugar content unless
you do something really stupid it's
probably going to be delicious so really
we're talking less about how to make an
acceptable homemade ice cream and more
about how to kind of take it to the next
level and make it a truly exceptional
dessert that you can make for friends
and on that note our friends that came
over they have family that owns a
custard shop yes and they were like I
think they were pretty blown away by the
highly competitive nature of your ice
cream versus the custard shop custard
I'll take it yeah so so really the main
thing you need to be worried about with
homemade ice cream is texture because
taste is gonna be good it's cream and
it's sugar and then as long as you don't
[ __ ] up the flavorings like taste is
fine texture is really what separates a
good ice cream from a bad ice cream and
texture is really hard to get right for
a homemade ice cream people who make it
professionally especially people who
mass manufacture it have a lot of
industrial stabilizers that they will
put in which helps the ice cream not
[ __ ] up during shipping so you know I
don't think that's a bad thing but like
typically they're gonna be using stuff
that home cooks either won't have access
to or won't have easy access to and also
the machinery you use can make a
difference as well so apparently for the
perfect ice cream texture that largely
depends on how fast you whip the ice
cream that determines how much air you
can get into it so there are consumer
devices that cost I think in excess of a
thousand bucks if not it's at least a
few hundred bucks where you can control
like the speed the paddles turn but that
that's probably not something that an
amateur ice cream maker is going to
invest in and I know that the top of the
line is I believe called a Paco jet
and what you what you do with that is
instead of you know putting the cream
mixture within a bowl and then you spin
around and it freezes as as the thing
turns you actually just freeze the
mixture solid and then it has a blade
with a assload of horsepower behind it
that beats the already frozen cream
mixture which helps break up any ice
crystals that have formed within the
mixture and so you get like a super
super smooth decadent ice cream from
that but anyway you're probably not
gonna have access to any of that stuff
as a home cook so your main the main
struggle you have is texture so there's
a couple ways to make ice cream that's
gonna have an appealing texture and it's
going to keep well in your freezer the
name of the game is you're trying to
have a bunch of little ice crystals
instead of a few large ice crystals the
way to get a bunch of tiny ice crystals
is basically to emulsify the mixture as
well as possible and to have as many
things that are going to absorb water as
possible so there's not just a bunch of
extra water floating around that can
form those large ice crystals so there's
two ways you can approach that one is
with emulsifiers and so here we're
talking egg yolks I think your best bet
for homemade ice cream that's going to
keep in your freezer for a long time is
to go frozen custard style with egg
yolks in it and then also to add
stabilizers that you will have access to
so here I'm thinking xanthan gum skim
milk powder and cornstarch the protein
content and the milk powder and just I'm
not totally sure how xanthan gum works
I'm not going to try to [ __ ] an
explanation and then with cornstarch per
unit of volume it just absorbs an
assload of water to help keep their from
being free water in the mixture that can
float around and form large ice crystals
so
here's how you make a super super good
homemade ice cream base you start with a
pint of cream and a cup of milk you put
that on the stove over medium low heat
you go ahead and throw in a quarter
teaspoon of xanthan gum you can probably
find that at most stores it's pretty
common now a lot of vegans use xanthan
gum as an egg substitute so as more
stores have become have started catering
to the to a vegan lifestyle xanthan gum
has become more ubiquitous you're giving
me a face they just eat plain xanthan
gum as a no no no like not as like
scrambled eggs but if you're oh like it
if if like a brownie recipe calls for an
egg okay you would use xanthan gum I was
like do that that is a bridge too far
you know no John I yes I understand that
face now so so xanthan gum is more
forgiving than a lot of other
stabilizers which is why I go with that
so you're gonna throw it in the milk and
cream mixture as it's coming up to
temperature make sure you whisk it in
really well so it fully dissolves and
you just keep that over medium-low heat
keep an eye on the temperature
eventually you want that to get up to a
hundred and eighty degrees Fahrenheit
which is some number of degrees Celsius
that's part of the metric system that I
can't do conversions with super quickly
yet so 180 degrees Fahrenheit that's
what you're aiming for while that's
coming up to temperature what you want
to do is crack some eggs get eight eight
egg yolks you can save the whites for
whatever you would want to use egg
whites for scrambled egg whites egg
white omelets want to make some
meringues go for that you can't throw
them out but if you're trying to reduce
food waste there are plenty of other
things you can use the whites for we
just need the yolks you're gonna get
eight egg yolks to that you're going to
add between three quarters of a cup to
one cup of sugar depending how sweet you
want your ice cream
and you're also going to add two
tablespoons of skim milk powder for the
protein content and one tablespoon of
cornstarch you're gonna want to whip
that mixture up really well you can use
a hand whisk or you can use a whisk but
a hand blender is probably going to be a
lot quicker and more efficient and you
just want to get that mixture until it's
relatively thin in ribbony so once
that's whipped up then you're just
tending the milk and cream mixture until
it gets up to 180 degrees Fahrenheit
when it gets to that temperature you're
going to ladle out about a cup of that
mixture into your egg mixture and as you
pour it in you whisk it in very quickly
and very well repeat the process a
couple times that will help your yolks
get up to temperature gradually it's not
going to shock them so you don't wind up
with scrambled eggs
once you've whisked a couple cups of the
milk and cream mixture into your eggs
you pour that back into the pot where
everything is simmering and you let that
mixture get up to a hundred and 70
degrees Fahrenheit stirring constantly
that's going to be hot enough to make
sure the eggs get fully integrated into
the mixture but it's going to be cool
enough that it doesn't cook the egg
yolks again you don't want to wind up
with scrambled eggs so once it hits a
hundred and seventy degrees Fahrenheit
then you pour it into whatever container
you're gonna make ice cream in like the
I don't know like jug thing on the ice
cream maker itself pour it through a
fine mesh sieve so you can filter out
any like you know if there's a chunk of
cornstarch still in it or if some of the
eggs did scramble a little bit it's
gonna strain those things out just make
sure you have a nice silky creamy ice
cream base left and then you turn it the
next day so that's for just plain ice
cream that's just milk and sugar on top
of that you can add any sort of
flavorings you want so I've done plain
vanilla I've done cookies and cream done
pistachio I've done ooh salted caramel
that was the best that's that's the most
reason I was really good so for the
salted caramel instead of mixing the
sugar in with the eggs instead I turned
the sugar into caramel sauce and used
that instead of like adding additional
sugar but yeah I mean really once you
have the base down the world is your
oyster whatever you're using for
flavoring throw that into the milk and
cream mixture as it's coming up to
temperature the longer it's in the hot
liquid the more it's gonna steep the
more it's going to impart its flavor
into your ice cream be I mean really the
base is the key if you can get a good
ice cream base you can make some good
[ __ ] ice cream and between the
emulsification from the eggs the
stabilization from the xanthan gum
stabilization from the protein and the
skim milk powder and just the sheer
water absorption capability from the
cornstarch you're going to wind up with
a very thick luscious creamy ice cream
that unlike most homemade ice creams
keeps super well in the fridge and yeah
it's good stuff all right and so for for
next week's episode I am gonna do a deep
dive into shredded chicken I think
really getting in the details about how
to make it in the crock-pot different
kind of vegetables and sauces you can
eat with it so we'll clear out some
space for that next week I think that
does it for this week's Q&A episode I
guess I guess food questions are on the
table now I don't really get it I feel
like shredded chickens fine and I get it
but I mean if people like it then people
like it but as always if you have
questions that you want answered about
training volume or creatine or how to
cook stuff you can always send us those
questions on social media the links to
all those different social media threads
will be provided in the description of
this episode thanks as always for
listening and we'll see you next time
thanks for listening to the stronger by
science podcast now Greg and I are not
experts in medicine or health or really
anything else for that matter so before
you make any changes to your diet and
exercise habits make sure you check with
a doctor or another health care
professional if you enjoyed this podcast
and you'd like to support it visit
stronger by science com2 check out the
products and services that we offer
thanks for listening and we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you